it's been about a month since apple
revealed the studio display and somehow
it's managed to be more controversial
than the mac studio that it launched
with and that's probably for two reasons
the price tag and the spec sheet that on
the surface seems underwhelming compared
to the lg 5k display that it's meant to
supersede so what i'm gonna try to do in
this review is not only explain exactly
why the studio display costs a huge
sixteen hundred dollars but also why
there are actually quite a few people
out there who are willing to pay that
much for this display and before you
call me crazy because this display has
basically the same panel as the old lg
5k display i can tell you for a fact
that it does not because we've actually
had the lg 5k in our office since it
launched five and a half years ago from
when we still work for apple insider and
if you're wondering if the studio
display is truly worth the extra three
hundred dollars i can tell you right now
that the answer is yes but before i
explain why i want to give you guys my
thoughts on the studio display after
using it for over three weeks so let's
jump right into that for the past couple
of weeks i've had this new studio
display set up literally right next to
my imac pro which packs essentially the
same 5k display that went into the lg 5k
ultra fine and let me tell you right now
the difference has been night and day i
won't go too much into the display panel
comparison just yet but all i can say is
that i found myself occasionally mashing
the brightness key on the imac pro
because it just looks dim and gray in
comparison to the bright and white
studio display but in terms of the
overall aesthetic the studio display
just looks so much more clean and
minimalistic compared to the imac pro
because first of all the bezels are much
thinner and it obviously does not have a
chin the top and bottom are lined with
circular vents for things like the
speakers and the exhaust and i really
love the shape of the stand because it
matches the overall design compared to
the imac pro and the build quality of
the stand is unmatched because it's
literally solid aluminum with a
minimalistic and really strong hinge
going around back it's simply the most
beautiful backside you'll see on any
display being incredibly minimalistic so
in terms of the design i think apple
absolutely nailed their goal of making
the display fit perfectly into their mac
lineup especially with the mac studio
and i think there are people out there
who will literally buy this display over
other much cheaper options because of
the design and premium build quality
itself and that's one of the reasons why
it makes sense to pay the extra 300
compared to the lg 5k because that
display is built mostly out of plastic
including parts of the stand and that
actually leads to a couple of different
issues first of all it shakes and
wobbles like mad as you can see in this
comparison to the studio display which
sits incredibly still on top of that the
bezels on the lg 5k are made out of
plastic which honestly makes it feel
pretty cheap compared to the new studio
display which features a solid piece of
glass covering the entire front
including the pure black bezels which
look a lot more premium as far as the
ports the ones on the studio display are
at least twice as fast in terms of
transfer speeds when connected to an
external ssd which is really convenient
if you want to use the display for
accessories instead of buying an
additional usb hub and of course it also
supports 96 watts of pass-through
charging for your macbook now another
massive difference that i noticed was
actually in the speakers which are
absolutely great giving you very clean
vocals sharp highs excellent mids and a
wide range of frequency reproduction
[Music]
so as you've just heard while the lg
speakers do get louder the quality is
nowhere near as good and the only thing
that is a little bit lacking on the
studio display is the base reproduction
that i wish was a bit more deep and loud
but other than that the sound quality is
excellent now in terms of the new 12
megapixel ultra wide webcam i honestly
feel like apple made a huge mistake by
going with the ultra wide sensor instead
of a standard zoom camera because when
you're not taking advantage of the new
center stage ultrawide feature the image
crops in quite a bit which leads to
lower than 720p quality that doesn't
look that much better than the lg 5k so
i really think apple should have just
stuck with a standard 12 megapixel
camera instead of going ultra wide but
nevertheless i honestly believe that the
difference in design build quality ports
and speaker quality is enough to make it
worth spending the extra 300
at least for people who care about those
things now of course we've also got a
lot of display panel differences than
the spec sheet would make you believe so
let's get into all of them first of all
it's been confirmed through teardowns
that the studio display uses a brand new
panel even though it boasts the same 5k
resolution and that kind of makes sense
because the new display is somehow quite
a bit brighter while at the same time
having much deeper contrast and i'm not
even kidding i can easily tell that the
blacks on the old lg display look a bit
gray when compared to the darker blacks
on the studio display and that
difference alone makes the colors pop
more and really makes the image look a
lot better but going even further apple
has dramatically reduced the
reflectivity of the new display compared
to the lg 5k which by itself can make
the display look a lot better especially
when used in a bright room and to put
the cherry on top the extra 100 nits of
brightness is a much bigger deal than i
initially expected and it's actually the
reason why hdr content looks so much
better because apple is using a method
called edr to simulate hdr content and
the extra brightness makes a world of a
difference looking better than many
other displays out there that claim to
support hdr you only have up to three or
four hundred nits of brightness so with
that said if you combine all of those
differences then it's pretty obvious
that anybody willing to pay 1300 for the
lg 5k should really consider going up to
the studio display instead to take
advantage of all of those differences
and a huge overlooked benefit of paying
apple extra cash for the studio display
is that you also get apple's higher
level of quality control since there
were many complaints of backlight bleed
issues and other quality control issues
with the lg 5k like wi-fi signal
interruption and so far the studio
display seems to solve all of those
problems now on top of that another
benefit that you get with the studio
display is resale value because it's
actually apple branded and people
recognize and pay for that because they
know that they can trust apple's build
quality and the actual quality control
including how apple does an excellent
job with calibrating the colors out of
the factory compared to a lot of other
displays that require you to manually
calibrate the colors if you're doing
serious work on them and all of those
things that i just listed are the
reasons why somebody would be crazy
enough to pay sixteen hundred dollars
for an apple studio display because
there are a lot of professionals out
there who do photography videography 3d
modeling cad and different types of work
and they would much rather just pay more
for a super high quality 5k apple
display that they can simply plug in and
trust and that right there is the target
market for this display so to someone
who just needs a simple display just to
satisfy the requirement of throwing
pixels up in front of their eyes so they
can browse the web of course this
display is going to seem grossly
overpriced and for a person like that
yes it is and they'd be much better off
with a basic 4k display like this 27
inch dell monitor for 380 on amazon but
nevertheless i will admit that this
display is still overpriced at sixteen
hundred dollars considering the fact
that you used to be able to buy an
entire 27-inch imac for eighteen hundred
dollars and if you're looking for an
explanation as to why this display cost
sixteen hundred dollars in the first
place there are two main reasons for it
first of all inflation and supply chain
shortages have been squeezing profit
margins for many companies including
apple so the sixteen hundred dollar
price tag partly has to do with apple
making sure that they'll hit their
target profit margins even if things get
worse and second multiple teardowns
including the one from quinn at
snazzylabs have confirmed that the
studio display is over engineered to say
the least in fact this display is
jam-packed with more logic board and
various components than apple's actual
24-inch imac computer but wait this
display is technically a computer
because it comes with an entire a13 chip
straight from an iphone 11 to support
features like center stage spatial audio
and hey siri on intel based machines so
it literally runs ios complete with 64
gigs of storage that is mostly unused so
technically this display is a giant ipad
and apple literally could run it as a
giant ipad if they wanted to but they
obviously won't because a lot of people
would simply buy the display without the
mac which would make apple lose
potential revenue so yes apple over
engineered the crap out of this display
compared to the lg 5k regardless of
whether you wanted it to or not and
maybe it's because it was initially
meant to be an imac like quinn from
snazzylabs was thinking as well as my
own theory i posted to twitter just
after the event so maybe we'll see a lot
of these internal components going into
the future 27-inch imac but with all
that aside over engineered or not i
think there are definitely a lot of
professionals out there who care about
design features build quality and
control quality and to them the 1600
studio display is going to be well worth
the cash so hopefully you enjoyed this
review and if you did go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out our
comparisons right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]